it was a crazy it was just like a dream
come true sugar cane parting is such
sweet sorrow away just want to say thank
you for seeing something in this old
lady thank you so much
[Music]
remember sugar is so sweet and I'll see
you real soon
[Music]
your time on the show is over what do
you hope The fans walk away remembering
you for or thinking about you
I hope the fans remember that like I
have a good heart and I'm very sweet and
that I just want to spread love and I
want people to recognize that like or to
remember that they can do the same they
just treat everyone with respect and
kindness and love and just have fun
life's too short if you had to boil down
your drag race experience into just a
couple words what would those words be
absolutely insane that's it it was crazy
did you make some friends for life in
this group absolutely the girls here are
like every single one of them at the end
of the day is just so incredibly sweet
and I really truly made some wonderful
wonderful family and I will keep forever
[Music]